[Music]
Kirby games are guaranteed to have the
following
candy-coated platforming levels a
cheerful pink mascot and numerous
power-ups to wield and combine these are
all key pieces of kirby star allies a
mostly traditional Kirby game designed
with co-op in mind via with three AI or
player driven cohorts you've been able
to team up in previous games like Kirby
Return to Dreamland on wheat but it's
fundamental to Star allies and far more
flexible in practice rather than being
limited to only playing alongside key
characters like Meta Knight or King
Dedede you can now recruit almost any
enemy you come across and after you
unlock a pair of extra modes upon
completing the story you earn the right
to play as any character in the game
I'll be it in a mini speedrun mode it's
not a massive sea change given that
enemies play the same as Kirby does
weenies absorb their powers but for a
game built around its variety of
personalities
it's an appreciated bonus
[Music]
start allies perfectly execute its
playful cartoon aesthetic from start to
finish
stuffed with adorable animations and
digital glitter now that you can borrow
powers from your allies or team up in
specific scenarios say when you have a
chef power up and pretend to cook your
friends in a pot to produce life-giving
snacks a charismatic moment is never
more than a button press away and being
able to share powers or take control of
an alternate set of skills makes Kerby
feel like a more capable hero overall
even if he doesn't really need the help
the story mode paces itself remarkably
well - in part because it's so short
procession of new ideas from one stage
to the next
keeps you wondering what clever
platforming obstacle or powerup lies in
wait he surprises may force your team to
split up to tackle simple large-scale
puzzles a feat the AI handles
effortlessly without your input you also
occasionally group together to roll
downhill as a wall smashing wheel hop on
the back of a flying star for some
casual side-scrolling shooter action or
line up to form a train and steamroll
through enemies reaching the end of a
level or world is generally very easy
the only real challenge in each level is
to locate hidden items puzzle pieces
that are used to complete pictures not
unlike the 3d a StreetPass game puzzle
swap each stage has a unique pink piece
that you can regularly find randomized
blue pieces - or tap amiibo to generate
them on-the-fly the pictures you unlock
are just that pictures which is a little
deflating as far as rewards go but rare
levels containing hidden rooms with a
switch that unlocks a new stage in the
overworld lion wait you're told when a
stage contains a hidden opportunity so
the challenge is to simply keep an eye
out for a suspicious-looking object or a
door during your travels
on some occasions an obstacle or object
requires you to interact while using a
specific ability such as electrifying a
power line or igniting a pile of leaves
never one to make you suffer though
enemies with the relevant power-ups are
generally placed nearby so you won't
feel regret for potentially being
unprepared strolling through the story
mode ensures a generous amount of
expertly crafted whimsy and joy but
because levels are so easygoing with
lightweight platforming in a trio of
friends watching your back at all times
star allies campaign quickly runs out of
steam it's almost a good problem to have
a game that's so good that you don't
want it to end but it's tough to shake
the disappointment when you cross the
finish
[Music]
the unlockable extra modes then are the
games saving grace
never mind the woodchopping and meteor
batting minigames which are cute but
undeniably shallow the boss rush and
speed run modes are the main attractions
for the speedrun mode guest star you
charge through five sets of levels as
the star allies character of your
choosing
these are some of the same stages you've
played before but the further you get
the faster stronger and more resilient
you become your gradual growth robust
set of actions per character and the
race against time inject star allies
with the energy to match his overflowing
personnel and to account for the lack of
difficulty elsewhere the boss rush mode
dubbed the ultimate choice can be dialed
up to unforgiving levels where enemies
hit harder health replenishments are in
shorter supply and more bosses line up
to battle both this and the speedrun
mode can be enjoyed with a total of four
players which feels more beneficial
compared to the pushover story
start allies is yet another great Kirby
game it's an artistic showcase and a
great opportunity for both relaxing and
challenging co-op platforming the only
real complaint you can levy at it is
that it gates off it's more challenging
aspects but the fact that they are
present to begin with will please anyone
who's grown weary of the series painless
platform
[Music]
you